What?
Listen
Hey, YouTubers this is going to be my episode 4 video
We can finally talk about it freely just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
We're officially halfway through the season
So if you are finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything
There's a new round of the hbo now giveaway - I'll still be doing that for the rest of the year
But there were so many big reveals in this episode even though it was the shortest of the season
So let's do top 10 wtF and book references starting with number 10. We finally get a solid bran scene
I'm so happy Jerome Flynn is back
He's one of the best actors on the show
So just like diana rigg queen of thorns they expanded that part just because he's so fantastic
But you can kind of tell how he's a little bit of Jaime's conscience
But he's also reminding you that he knows exactly who he is
He's kind of a hound type character where yet he recognizes that
He does a lot of bad things
But he's coming to the point where he's starting to question the morality of it all like when Jaime asked him to go use his
Talents to get the grain from all the farmers of the reach
And they thread in this really cool idea of the more you have the more troubles you have the more ways you down
Making you wonder if Maybe Jaime will not be quite
So way down by the end of the season how much longer is it going to be before he takes that Cersei chain from around?
His neck and throws it on the ground and by the end of the episode bran sort of sees his gold sack lying there
leaves it so it implies that he's going to be much more free for the rest of the season to less burden by some of
The more terrible things that they've been doing the last couple of episodes
Another well time Rick and joke triggering everybody again, Rickon. No dicking
So Jaime is like slowly showing his true
Colors like he'll come around eventually he just doesn't quite got to that point yet
But number 9 the iron bank is so happy that they're getting their money back
But terrified at the idea that they'll lose the business of the crowd
This is one of those really funny sinister moments where Cersei is like. Yes
I'm getting everything that I want my plan is clear and ty conus taurus is sort of like keeping up over the s-Say
Hey
Is there anything else that we can help you with?
Maybe there's another giant loan that you need I don't remember what the exact debt of the crown is but it was several million
Crowns
I believe like it's just meant to be this astronomical figure that you could barely fathom literally everything they have used to repay this debt
Overnight, so they're just like this is amazing, but please let us give you another loan so we can start collecting on that one
too we love making money off of you guys as
Great as that is the really big thing here though is the name drop of the Golden company
So if you're not a book reader, the Golden company was actually formed by Black Buyers after the Blackfyre Rebellion, Daemon
Blackfyre the last known possessor of the blade black fire that belonged to aegon targaryen
Which rightfully belongs to daenerys now was driven into exile after the first blackfyre rebellion he passed that along to his
Descendants the sword ended up being lost, but the Golden company became this amazing Mercenary company
They would just relentlessly pursue their Target
They have a golden reputation for delivering on their contracts, so the iron bank says. Oh, yes, we use them to collect on delinquent loans
Cersei implies that they're going to be hiring them to bolster their forces and now it sounds like they definitely need them because of all
The troops that daenerys killed no idea they'll include jon, Connington, or if they'll include any aegon references?
They might wink at that, but because they've been rushing the story forward so quickly
I think they're mostly focusing on the jon snow Targaryen reveal
So I don't think we're going to see any surprise alternate targaryen popping up, but number 8 Chaos is a ladder brand knows
Everything so we talked about this in previous videos. What are brand's powers
What does he know does he secretly peep on everybody in Westeros, so the way the brand explains it is that he knows?
Everything that's happened, but the problem is is that he can't focus on it
And he's so inhuman now that it's really hard to communicate with them effectively
but within that same Breadth
littlefinger gives him the cat's paws the Valyrian dagger that was used to try and kill him during season 1 and it seems like he's
Just trying to butter him up like he thinks that he's going to become the new lord of Winterfell
So I better get in good with him. I'd better start working my claws into him the way
I'm working them into Sansa, but if they haven't been clear buff for this episode
Definitely wanted to let you know that the star children are starting to become a wolfpack and littlefinger is the lone wolf now
So lone wolf dies pack survives the important thing to remember though is that even though brand knows
Everything that littlefinger's done his role in Ned Stark's death before anybody could revenge kill littlefinger
They would have to prove his treachery to the other lords of the vale so they would continue to back
Sansa in house stark even without littlefinger around his role in John Aaron's death would be a really solid way to do that
John Royce there would probably strangle littlefinger himself if he found out that littlefinger had a big role in Killing Jon, Arryn
So depending on what happens we can revisit that stuff, but it's all callbacks to season one this season
They reference a lot of arya stuff from season one in the episode
So when it comes to littlefinger's downfall, it'll probably have something to do with what he did preceding or during season one
But loved that brand meera scene he is such a dick you died in that cave
They just want to make him seem like he's gone full-blown, Dr.. Manhattan. He's lost his humanity so Mira is out of there
We're probably not going to hear from her for the rest of the season
We might not even see her during season eight
Maybe when she gets home she could tell howland reed to come show up and tell everybody about Jon snow
But number seven arya returns to winterfell so this is a very touching moment if you didn't recognize that
Song cue that they used as she was looking on the horizon there that's called winter has come that's literally the name of the song
Anytime there's a big stark scene. You hear it in the background
So it's kind of a stark theme winter is coming is their motto so winter like arya has come home
Just like winter has come
But all the funny moments with the guards as well as my number six
the fight with Brienne are just intended to show you
what her Ninja skills are like what she might look like when she's going after somebody
So they just want to make her seem like this really badass character
But I felt like the fight was actually pretty good one of the best arya fights
We've ever seen there's a lot of the bravo stuff that just didn't quite work for me as much
but if you really want to get down to it like if you really analyze their fight she would have zero chances against Brienne the
Realest moment of this fight was when Brienne kicked her across the courtyard like a sack of potatoes
She would crush arya no matter how she was but you have to imagine that there's a certain magical component
Arya's abilities so that could explain why someone her size could take on someone Bri inside and there were so many
references to syrio forel in her technique here most of her training came from the house of black and white
So when Brienne asks her who taught you how to fight like that and she says no one it's a bit of a wink at
The house of black and white, but she's holding her blade like syrio forel and the braavosi water dancers
So they just want to let you know that she still remembers all the things that serio taught her as well as what she learned
In the house of black and white so obviously the other side of this
Too is the callback to littlefinger watching this all play out and just taking it all in
So a fun part of this episode was just seeing how littlefinger reacted to all the supernatural stark children like oh
Oh, you know everything that I've done okay? I'm going to crap my pants now
I'll be back later
And then as surprised as he is by arya's actual abilities he also notices that she has the dagger that he just gave to brand
Making it pretty clear to him. How brand feels about the situation like I don't care about this dagger
I don't care about you, and I know everything that you've done so littlefinger
Just being backed into a corner slowly, but number five stark reunion
So there were a couple
reunions
You have orion Santa and the crypts then you have their reunion with brand so these could have been the worst moment of the episode
And I feel like this winterfell plot relies on their chemistry together, so if their scenes didn't work
You'd be forced to sit through a couple more hours of them together for the rest of the season
So it could have been really bad if it didn't work out
But I think that Maisie and Sophie Turner did a pretty good job with their scenes
They do a good job through their performances of letting you know what their relationship has been they've never gotten along
They'd never seen eye-to-eye
They've always been so different, but now that they've been through so much the idea is they come together they form this wolf pack
So I wouldn't be surprised if littlefinger tries to use that to his advantage in the next couple of episodes
We'll see if they actually end up doing that, but let me know in the comments
How you think that littlefinger is going to try and play his hand now
They all the stark children seem like they're coming together
But Arry and Sansa still aren't super crazy about each other remember chaos is a ladder
So he's gonna find some way to create more chaos
within the Stark family. But number four, back to Dragonstone, Jon and Daenerys in the cave
This is actually a really great scene
They want to show you some of the chemistry they have together and I do think that from their scenes so far
They've shown that they have chemistry on-screen together
But right up until the left turn that she makes it just meant to show that they're slowly coming around on each other jon
Snow's being as genuine as possible. "I need your help
I don't think that I can do this without you" in that really important line from Daenerys where she says "I will fight for you
Jon Snow"
so a
Preview of things to come but not before a bunch of other drama happens between now and then like they don't want to make it
Seem too easy even though you know what the end point is like obviously at some point
She's going to say that and mean it without forcing him to bend the knee
but the important thing here is all these cave drawings from the children of the forest so obviously, they're mostly used as an
Exposition tool, and you see that circular symbol show up that the knight king drew and that you saw when he was being created
So this symbol recurs alot, it'll probably come back a couple more times as well, so right now
It just seems like a reference to the cycle of ice and fire like this is where it all began
And this is where it all comes back to
They offhandedly
Referenced the war with the first men the pact that they signed on the isle of faces and John says a long long time ago
but in reality that was between 8 and
10,000 years ago in the book so you could say thousands of years ago on the TV show
But I did find myself wondering what the children of the forest were doing at Dragonstone
If there wasn't a weirwood there because you don't see them popping up to many places outside of the forest
So maybe at one point there were we're woods on Dragonstone
But of course she's off number three we get our reunion with theon he washes up on the beach and Jon snow
Oh, this is so great
So you haven't seen a moment with them together since season 1 and he knows everything that theon has done
He might even still think the brain is dead although
I wonder if Sansa told him everything that theon did because he says that's the only reason
I'm not killing you is because of what you did for Santa
But when Santa was rescued by fiat he told her that he didn't really kill bran and rickon
So I'm still betting on the idea that bran is dead
And he thinks that arya is probably dead, too
Because she hasn't made any reference to her these past seasons you would think somebody from winterfell with Ravin to Dragonstone
Oh by the way, John you're brother and sister that you thought were dead
Have just turned up
but we got to start talking about the last 15 minutes of the episode so good Daenerys attacks Jaime's Caravan with the Dothraki and
Drogon so poor Tyrion. He just gets thrown under the bus here enough your clever plans your plans are shit
I know, it seems like Daenerys has mad at him
But she's just really pissed off about how things have been going so I don't think there's going to be any really big
problems between them Within Daenerys of small Council
But before the battle the really important thing here is that she turns to John snow and says what the hell would you do in?
this situation pretty much tells her that you attack King's landing and burn it to the ground nobody's going to want to follow you and
Because she attacked Jaime's Caravan it means that she listened to his advice
So it's a really effective way of showing you what their status is right now
She's still being really stubborn about him bending the knee
But she is listening to his counsel she recognizes him as a full-blown ally at this point
So the battle the first real battle that we've gotten this season and one of the best ones that the show has done so far
Even though it's in one of the shortest
Episodes you get to see what the dothraki are capable of and if you don't remember it
There's this really amazing line that Robert Baratheon had when he said only a fool would meet the dothraki
In an open field so even though you have the added effect of Drogon here burning all this lannister soldiers
You still would have had this thunderous sea of Dothraki washing over them. I love the way
They make them sound like the storm Daenerys stormborn
It sounds like a storm is approaching
Just as the dothraki crests the hill in the dragon swoops in through the clouds so there's so much stuff going on here so much
Exposition that they get across as the battle starts as well
So just as a reminder
Randyll tarly rides up right before the dothraki attack and says the last of the gold has made it through the gates at King's landing
There were a lot of people that saw the preview after last week's episode and said well that gold is not getting to Cersei
She's not going to get her army
But because of randyll tarly is comment it means that cersei did get the gold and she will get those additional troops
So when you see Drogon, just burning the hell out of this Caravan here
That's all the grain that they collected from the farmers of the reach, so you see what they did there
They're balancing the playing field so daenerys
A bunch of her army she takes out a bunch of the lannister army if it wasn't clear the people that she killed were only
A small fraction of the lannister army that you saw at Highgarden so like all these other people
There's thousands of troops here this little piece of the Caravan that you're seeing is just like a small little bit of that
We watched rogue on almost get winged. He's down, but it hits him in his shoulder, so like Daenerys starts yanking it out
He'll probably be fine, but number one probably my favorite moment of the episode though is sir Jaime the dragon slayer
He was the king slayer now. He's going to try and be the dragon slayer
unsuccessfully so you see him charging
Drogon we have that great line from Tyrion and what I actually think is going on here
Is that he was trying to kill Daenerys not drogon?
And if it wasn't clear that's a bran snatching him off the horse at the end, so they're both fine
But they are at the Mercy of Daenerys his army now so we'll see what ends up happening
Next is he going to be their captive are they going to try and parlay with King's landing like we have your jaime
Maybe we can make a bargain. We'll give them back to you, but let me know in the comments
What was your favorite moment from the episode what will happen next is I'll do my trailer video
Then I'll post new Rick and morty
But if there are any bonus videos that you guys want me to do based on stuff in this episode
Just let me know in the comments
Congratulations to the latest Giveaway Winner Joyful
33 please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
while you wait for everything to post you can click here to learn all about Jon snow and
Dragons and you can click here for my episode 3 video. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight